he jacks it 12 points for him and he  just plays with  i don't want to call it a swagger  because it's not a confident or  cocky gate he just has his own little  way  he gives it away right there beasley in  a foot race with jackson  posting in a whistle and a foul and  beasley will go to line for a couple of  free throws  well you know what with reggie too i go  back to the professionalism part right  that being professional allows him now  to stay prepared when his name is called  his teammates  trust him because of the professional  that he is  when he gets in when he enters the game  [Applause]  i know chauncey phillips can i take some  of his ring can i claim some of that  but you're not that cool though i was i  was